detroit will save itself it's the only
possibility so when we get engaged
citizens engage businesses that's how we
truly change our neighborhoods and
that's how we you know empower ourselves
to be able to do this
detroit home to the big three american
automakers
factories that used to be sources of
pride now stand in ruins
it's hard to believe that thousands of
workers once assembled luxury cars here
parts of detroit resemble ghost towns
some 80 000 homes stand empty
and the unemployment rate here is double
the national average
but now some imaginative entrepreneurs
are fighting to change all that
phil cooley is one of them after
international success is a fashion model
he's come back to detroit i had a voice
i could participate here i didn't feel
the same way in manhattan and paris and
london and these other great cities that
i felt like i could participate
meaningfully and that i could you know
find community and that happens in
detroit because we're forced to work
together here because we have less
resources and we can do more with less
ultimately
for a small sum cooley purchased an
empty warehouse but he doesn't expect
his investment to make him rich
under the name pony ride he rents space
in it to creative startups
they pay just a quarter of the usual
rent
but in exchange they must do something
good for the community
small businesses like this blacksmith
shop show the local residents how to
make doorknobs and belt buckles
anyone can come here and use the
equipment
but where can people go for food
detroit has become a vast wasteland for
grocery shoppers
many supermarket chains have closed
and that's left residents to buy food at
gas stations and liquor stores
or eat fast food
regiania coleman is working hard to
bring healthier food to detroit suburbs
students get a discount on her fresh
squeezed juices
she hopes this will help them to develop
an appetite for better nutrition
so far coleman's only been able to cover
her costs
but the actions of one man show that
local residents want her juice bar to
thrive
he walked in and he placed a five dollar
deal on the counter he said you know i
said would you like something you know
what would you like say i don't want
anything i just want you to succeed and
so there are people who really recognize
what we're doing and they understand it
and they're very grateful
a lot of people are here a lot of people
where they're changing their eating
habits so i think this is perfect for
the community
detroit is known as the motor city
almost everyone here used to own a car
but today on some streets there's barely
an automobile inside
many must rely on the bus if one ever
comes
delays of up to four hours are normal
while many poorer neighborhoods have no
service at all
so andy de dorosi's goal is to develop
better bus service
he optimizes the routes using a simple
satellite app
ditarosi founded the detroit bus company
when he was just 24.
three years ago the engineer was still
fixing up the buses himself
today he has employees to do that
and he's put together a fleet of seven
buses
what we really want to do is find gaps
in the transit network basically
neighborhoods that don't have transit
population groups that don't have
transit and then fill those gaps by
offering services i really believe that
there's a time for for-profit businesses
and there's a time for non-profits but
frequently in the middle there's a time
for this sort of low profit liability
company this sort of like right right in
the middle solution
the bus service is financed through
ticket sales and donations
but what's really unusual is that it
also provides free rides
almost 6 000 last year alone
with their tickets paying customers
finance transportation for the poor
i love the way the bus looks i love the
driver i love the convenience of it the
location and their willingness to
transport people from here to the
eastern market so i think it's great
big companies like general motors still
dominate detroit's cityscape
but it's small businesses that are
working toward creating a more socially
just future
for me the 80s model of capitalism is
absolutely dead
it's dying a slow painful death because
there's so much money behind it and so
now it's about all of us gaining wealth
together being more sustainable being
more equal and just